good morning afternoon and evening to
everyone my name is Col and basically
i'll be talking about data science and
what and how it is adding to risk
analytics today the introduction is
already done so i would before going to
the next steps I'll just set some ground
rules so I think it's mostly going to be
a monologue in the beginning where I'll
just finish the presentation please keep
posting your questions I think that has
already been told to you and I will
answer in the end all your questions so
just keep posting them or don't wait
till the end in terms of posting your
questions setting the expectations I
know that there are people from varied
backgrounds so the expectation is to
give food for thought to everyone one
who knows data science but wants to know
more about risk analytics one who knows
risk management but wants to see the
application of data science and thirdly
those who are interested in both if you
do not belong to any of these categories
yes table so this is the agenda for
today it's just overview kind of a thing
like why data science many many of you
who are enthusiastic about data science
would have heard about these 3 v's which
is volume velocity and variety then we
will talk about the relationship of risk
analytics and data science and how data
science has been leveraged not just
today but for decades actually we'll
talk a bit about fraud analytics to an
extent I will then talk about a mini
case on operational risk for a
pharmaceutical manufacturer and then
I'll talk about
next steps so let me begin with why data
science of course you have the reasons
which is it adds competitive value it
prepares for likely scenarios which may
happen and that's where the predictive
analytics comes into the picture at many
companies it drives the strategy and
operations of course you need to be
careful where do you apply data science
at to what extent you apply and of
course it helps design vegetable
feedback systems which is very very
important in any industry in any
business measuring whatever you do is
very important and that is where data
analytics data science data mining comes
into the for now the question is why has
data science become so popular in the
last few years one of the big reasons
for that is of course big data and I
will be covering those three pieces as I
told you earlier the charger basically
tells you that the difference between
underperformance and outer fulness of
how they use their data so given these
statistics most of the companies these
days are moving towards using data
science in every of their functions and
today of course i will be talking
specifically for the risk management of
the risk analytics perspective starting
with the volume of data this is just to
give you an idea i think everyone would
have seen this unknown by now you guys
would have seen this like a gazillion
times but this is just to bring home the
point about how we are just surrounded
with data so you have like 2.5
quintillion bytes of data being
generated everything until it is
basically 18 zeros put put x 2.5 of
course there are other so many examples
of the amount of data that is being
generated today the going from volume we
will basically now go on to the variety
of data that is there
which which kind of adds into the to the
data that we have you can have data from
Twitter you can have data from facebook
you can have data from videos you there
are Lord and lot of variable and
wireless health monitors which are out
there which are generating data every
day every second so you basically have
lots and lots of data out there and and
and of course you also have the velocity
of data or the frequency of the rate of
data creation in a car they usually
there are hundred sensors imagine the
amount of data generated every right now
that we have the data and a reason to
use data science what do we ate of
course skilled people and this is where
this is a definition which is like very
very general there are there are a lot
of things that our data scientists
usually does from spotting the patterns
trying to find insights out out of that
data but broadly these are the three
skill sets that you see on your screen
right now which a data scientist should
have won the knowledge or the technical
knowledge which is computer science or
business intelligence as they say it
secondly the massive statistics behind
the concepts if you if that is something
and then people usually have 12 and I
have never never seen someone with all
three skill sets but people usually have
one of these and they usually move
around the circle and try to move Indian
the other circuit the other circles so
that they can at least move more closer
to being a data scientist and thirdly an
the most important is of course domain
expertise I feel that this is the most
important skill set as compared to the
normal technical computer science
background or the matter statistics
still set the other two quite literally
becomes academic if you do not have the
domain expertise
given this background I would like to
start with the risk analytics and how
data science is being used to do this
Cara tix for a number of years now and
of course as I already mentioned earlier
big data has given a new impetus to how
we go about doing risk analytics so
there are various industries which use
risk analytics there are various
functions within an industry which
deploy or this there's always actual
risk management in all the industries it
depends upon on which functions do we
apply the risk analytics it could be for
a finance it could be a financial risk
analytics it could be an operational
risk analytics it could be a marketing
analytics if you look at it from a
functional perspective if you look at it
from an industry perspective you have
these banks which usually use it you
have you you have health care industry
which uses risk analytics you have
enormous CPG industries which uses risk
analytics and I will talk about you have
the pharmaceutical industries of course
the case with which I am going to talk
today but all of them go back to the
previous question which is what actually
is risk management so risk management as
defined is an identification assessment
and prioritization of risk followed by
coordinated and economical application
of resources to minimize monitor and
control the probability or impact of
unfortunate events so let me make this
like in plain simple words it's
basically identifying the sources of
risk and then prioritizing which risk we
need to we need to look at look at all
the scenarios which the risk creates and
then accordingly act on that to minimize
your failure or to minimize your loss
because the moment when you save this it
is more or less trying to minimize the
loss that
you use me have applied across
industries it is basically applied occur
across financial risk analytics and so
as I already mentioned that there are a
lot of functions and industries across
which risk analytics is being applied
but today I will mostly talk about one
of the two main buckets which is the
financial risk analytics and the
operational risk analytics the case is
on operational risk analytics but I also
to an extent talk about financial base
Alex also broadly again financial risk
analytics the top three risks which
usually all the retail banks talk about
is the liquidity risk the credit risk
and the fraud risk analytics so we'll
talk about the fraud risk in some detail
as and I'll give some more devote more
time to fraud the risk analytics but I
will next also talk about liquidity and
credit risk now banks usually are in the
business of selling liquidity and
pursuing profit necessarily since
capitalization and leaves little margin
for error so it's not easy to predict
liquidity risk because the chances of it
happening is kind of binary so how do
you use data science into it you try to
predict the events which precede these
liquidity liquidity risk events if a
particular company or a bank goes into
or there is a high liquidity risk or
there is a chance of a bankruptcy what
happens is that there are certain events
which which happened before it and this
is where data science comes into the
picture where it tries to predict these
events now the problem is that these
events don't happen
regular basis you will find that even
with the fraud analytics that I will
talk about in my next slide because
these events don't happen so frequently
it is not easy to predict them but then
given the advent of big data because we
have so much of data we can actually
start to model these kind of random or
rare events that that happened the
second risk is basically the credit risk
in credit risk basically what you try to
do is you calculate the probability of
loan defaults as a company I would want
to know or as a bank I would want to
know whether my creditor will default or
not default it is tell you what happens
is when you give a loan to a creditor
you usually look at his current at a
status current situation at his current
capability but but what data science
does or what big data does is now you
can look at the future or you can look
continuously at how the the credibility
of a creditor changes with time you can
look through the bank transactions that
that creditor would have done you can
look at let's say some kind of a
conversation on the phone conversation
that person would have done or that
creditor would have done it could be a
person individual person it could be a
company it also depends on on if you
have some kind of a social media data on
that particular particular company of
course there are other things like you
could have share prices if it's a
company you could have income levels if
it's an individual person so all these
factors are usually considered when
you're trying to calculate the
probability of your own default and this
again its data signs which helps to
calculate that probability or are get
the model through which you can get the
credit line
third kind of of risk analytics in a
financial risk domain is the fraud risk
and I'm going to talk in detail about it
as i am going to give little bit more
time i'll also give an example which
recently happened with me few weeks ago
second year the second bucket that we
will talk about today is the operational
risk analytics now in any business
operations is the one which affect which
is affected by lot of forces think of
let's say I think many of you would have
already heard about the Potter five
forces theory so all these forces leads
to different kinds of operational risk
on a on a business and which leads to
certain scenarios which needs to be
prevented and this is where again data
science comes into the picture where
what we try to do is we try to predict
the kind of risks that could happen on
that basis we create scenarios once we
have created that scenarios then as a
business we are ready to deal with each
one of them and then as of today we try
to make sure that the actions that we
take today tries to cover if not most of
the scenarios most of the reason is that
we have created today's case we'll also
talk about that it's a mini kids so it
talks about how we can create scenarios
how we can prepare accordingly not going
back to fraud analytics so what usually
happens in ER and fraud analytics is
that you are trying to predict a fraud
it could be in examples let's say if if
I am transacting something online and if
there is some kind of a fraud going on
then as a retail bang could we need to
find out
if there is a certain fraud for a
certain transaction 11 example could be
that a particular person usually spends
a certain amount in a month and then
suddenly the there is a spike in his
spending which is much much more higher
than earlier then that's like one of the
most simplest ways of saying or
predicting that maybe there is a fraud
going on and how do you find it
technically how do you find it
mathematically you find it through the
help of outliers so usually you have a
uniform kind of a consumption or a
uniform kind of transaction through up
through a bank son giving an example
through let's say a credit card example
so you usually spend uniformly or there
are certain things which you usually do
and then suddenly if there is some kind
of an outlier it could be an outer in
terms of not just the amount that you
spend but also the locations from which
the transactions have been made for
example if if you usually make your
transactions online from two or three
locations usually and if suddenly the
city changes now that's an outlier so
outline is not just about the the amount
that you spend on the values that you
get it is also bought these categorical
values that you have when you look at
bank transactions know how does are in
data science come into the picture these
outliers they have certain patterns and
what would you like to do is try to
model these outliers if you model these
outliers you can actually predict when
the fraud is when the fraud is going to
happen you may you may think it's a rare
and a random event but the outliers are
also usually defined to be to be random
but with so much computational power
and big data it is this ability to model
these outliers which helps us with fraud
analytics just to give you an example of
something which happened with me a few
weeks ago this is what came to me this
was a male which literally came to my
inbox which said that we are concerned
that some recent transactions on your
account might not have been authorized
by you we try to call you to verify the
transaction but did not reach you to
protect your account we need to confirm
this activity with you I thought this
was just like email which did not need
any action of course they block my
account in the next seven days how did
they find that out of course there would
be a lot of modeling going on behind it
and the reason was that I had so I asked
them the reason why or which transaction
what is the transaction because of which
they think that it's a fraudulent
transaction I had basically booked a
flight from Chicago to Seattle and they
felt it was a scam because there were
some fraudulent transactions going on
specifically in that time period for
that airline and the pattern of my
booking mashed with the model that they
had created so it's basically this
ability of of data analytics to model
these outliers which helps us to execute
fraud fraud analytics so this kind of to
an extent I ends the the financial
analytics part now I will move on to the
next part which is a small mini kids on
a pharma manufacturer usually I could
have easily taken a case on financial
risk analytics which is majorly where
rest antics is used but I also feel that
risk management is there in every
business and that's the reason why I
picked up
a pharmaceutical manufacturer do from
whatever feels you are in you can easily
relate to the example or to the case
that I am giving right now okay and
before before I move on to the case
please post your questions if you have
any questions I will try to answer them
to the best of my capacity okay so a
pharmaceutical manufacturer has a
strategic business decision to make it
has to it has to make a capacity
strategy which needs to be made today on
the basis of certain factors there are
lot of factors which go into making a
strategy so I am NOT going to go into
details of every one of them I mean it
could be beside these four factors there
could be geographic location of an asset
timing of opening the asset they could
be some kind of a long to business
strategy of acquiring more customers or
or taking a loss and trying to increase
market share so there are lot of other
factors which I have not considered but
these are basically the full main
factors that are considered for the case
the type of drug the demand for that
drug the suppliers who are going to give
me the raw materials or or the finished
sub parts of my drugs and the choice of
my asset specialized versus flexible now
what I'll just try to explain the
specialized versus flexible unit so by
specialized what I mean is that if I
have like two types of drug a and B and
in our case we have two types of drug ed
to have two different or one individual
unit for each truck so I will need to
have two units for a and B whereas a
flexible unit is a unit which can
produce both a and B of course flexible
here it come
with its own cost and specialized will
be little cheaper but then if you look
at the long-term you will find that
there are trade-offs between getting a
specialized unit and a flexible unit and
this is something that we need to decide
now looking at these you may feel where
does theta signs come into the picture
well it's it's not a parent but
basically the type of a drug a drug in a
pharmaceutical industry has to go
through this through a cycle where FDA
needs to approve it so there is a
certain probability of the drug being
approved which needs to be accounted for
and and what happens in this industry is
that the moment when your drug has been
approved you need to start the product
to production as quickly as possible
because you have a patent life and if
you do not produce during that period
you are going to miss billions and
billions of dollars of profit so today
you need to decide that what is the
probability of a drug being approved and
according to that get ready with your
protection plans get ready with your
units demand demand again if you go back
demand forecasting is something which is
very very important again data science
comes into the picture the accuracy of
that demand is very very important
because on that basis I am going to look
at the capacity of the goods being used
suppliers again very important how does
data science again come into the picture
reliability of the suppliers what is and
again the reliability of the suppliers
can again be modeled or measured on the
basis of data sites choice of acid it's
an effect of your our type of drug
demand and supply outs and of course
there are other things like financial
constraints which I am not right now
looking at now when we talk about Doug
approved drug approval probability
there's a lot of factors
on which it kind of depends it depends
upon whether it's a large molecule drug
or a small molecule drug there are a lot
of areas in which your drug could be in
it could be an oncology drug it could be
a cancer drug in would be infectious
disease drug now all these factors
actually contribute to being approved or
not being approved by the FDA and you
need to model that demand forecasting
then two types of i'll talk about in
details both for durable probability and
demand forecasting there are in two
types of forecasting the time series
forecasting and the cause and effect
forecasting both of them needs of course
knowledge of models and knowledge of how
usually a demand forecasting how demand
forecasting works as already mentioned
to you supply reliability lead time
variability and raw material quality so
these are again things which need to be
modeled and your supply reliability
completely depends upon how much time
the supplier takes for your raw
materials or in this case finished
molecules to come to your client so
let's go into detail on drug approval
probability so what I'll try to do in
this case is zoom in and zoom out as and
go into the details and then go out and
try to talk at the strategic level so
you should be ready and I think as as
business professionals we should all be
ready to go to the details and then come
out think broadly but keep going either
details so that's the reason why I have
mentioned the data sources from where
you could get this data so there is
something called as it's just an example
there are lot of ways in which you can
store the store the data for R&D which
pharmaceutical company does one of the
ways is and I've worked on a
pharmaceutical client with a
pharmaceutical client for
to have something called as project
systems which is a module in ASAP you
could also have the FDA historical data
so these are some data sources which you
need to have to to calculate the
approval probability travel tools
potential to source office which would
be used or are used in all of the
process ACP sequel RSS at tableau so how
how do you calculate that you start with
the descriptive you move on to the
predictive and then thirdly you do the
prescriptive what do I mean by that when
I say descriptive what you're trying to
do is you're trying to look at the
relationships between different
variables and trying to see if there is
an effect on the probability so you have
as I mentioned earlier so you have a
large molecule drug and a small molecule
drug you have a different areas in which
you usually have your drug the oncology
our cancer drug or infectious disease
time of the year number of clinical
trials it could also be that how many
trials are you doing the approval by an
FDA could depend upon the number of
trials that you have done or the quality
of trials that you have done the kind of
sampling that you have done for your
trials so there are a lot of these
factors which go into creating a drug
and all of these could affect the
probability that your drug is going to
get approved or not and what descriptive
analytics does is basically it gives you
or it gives you the relationship or it
helps you understand the whole system
and it gives you the relationship
between these variables once you
understand the whole system the next
thing is to predict the system so the
first part is understanding the system
for descriptive analytics then you move
on to predictive analytics where you use
different models to predict the
probability of your approval so in this
in this
case you can use models like logistic
regression you could use things like
neural networks so these are models
through which you can actually calculate
the probability and once you create that
model the next part is the is the
prescription part now what do we mean a
prescription the point here is that I
would want to increase the probability
of my drug approval and if I need to
increase the probability then I need to
make sure that all the controlling
factors that i have in my hand i try to
tweak it in such a way so that i can get
the maximum probability i would want to
increase the probability of my approval
because quite literally that means that
i can i can make my plants much better
because if i know that something is
going to happen ninety percent more
times then it is easy for me to take a
decision if there is something which
happens only ten percent a time then it
becomes difficult for me to decide what
should i do next that's why my purpose
through prescriptive analytics is to
make sure that i increase the
probability so it could be just to give
you a fact so i was just going through
some cases on drug approval some
articles basically and what what had
mentioned was that oncology and small
molecule drug are something which fda
approves much frequently than other kind
of drugs so as a company you could say
that i am taking a strategic decision to
move towards creating drugs which are in
the area of oncology and are basically
small molecule drug okay for people from
the finance background you can think of
this as trying to probable to find the
probability of a loan default or let's
say people from a retailer cpg you can
think of probability of a campaign
effectiveness and its effect on the
night basically this probability is
going to
pletely if affect the demand of the of
my drug in this case there there are two
drugs a and B and the probability is
going to affect the expected demand for
that drug and once you have the expected
demand then accordingly you will decide
whether I should have a specialized unit
or whether i should have a flexible unit
moving on to the second part where data
science is used is forecasting I think
this is something which is known to many
of you but still the accuracy of
forecasting is is very very important in
all the cases so again you have two
types of it and I tell you the
difference as and where and when is it
used so one is the time series it's
basically used everywhere it's one of
the most easiest way of doing
forecasting which is you have time on
your x-axis and you have demand on your
y-axis and on the basis of time there
are things which are there is something
called seasonality there is something
called cyclicity there's something
called a level and there's something
called a trend so these are like four
components of any time series data that
you may have you will take these four
components you will model them in
different tools it could be done on I it
could be done on SAS it could be done on
any analytical tool ah this is this
example that i'm showing you was done on
on tableau and are on the left hand side
and and on that basis you do your
forecasting talking about the sand and
what happens in a time since forecasting
is more or less it kind of gives you a
point estimate there could be a range of
demand but more or less it's a point
estimate as in if a certain condition
changes suddenly you won't be able to
get the demand because time series
assumes that whatever conditions
happened throughout a year will repeat
itself this year too that is something
which time series demand or time series
model assumes what
happens is in a cause and effect
forecasting is that it doesn't assumes
you it takes in all the variables which
actually affects your demand and then on
that basis you can actually tweak those
livers and if those levers change duty
during a year you can actually get the
or you can actually set them are like in
this case for for our case it could be
that there is a there is of course the
price factor on mr. demanding will
change which is more like a price
elasticity that you which is like the
classic economic theory in this case
then there are other factors like
competition if there is a certain
competition or there is another
pharmaceutical company which is which is
your big competitor on that basis again
your prices may change and other bases
your demand may change so all these
factors kind of affect the demand of
your of your drug there are other things
too in this case I it's more like a CVG
context the the winter flag basically is
what time of the year is it then what
what was the rainfall in that year so
these are these are dependent on the
industry in which you are if I talk
about the financial domain it would be a
cash flow forecast so you want to
forecast the revenues you want to
forecast the cost of goods sold or or
what you could do is to predict your
operating cash you could look at cost of
capital probability of default you could
look at the share price individually you
could look at the income levels and the
credit ratings if you are looking at an
individual creditor so there are these
different factors which needs to be
considered in a cause and effect
forecasting once you have a good
forecast
and and and you have a good probability
in this case you you now know that the
probability of a passing through the FDA
is certain X X and X has to be from 0 to
14 B it is some Y and then you also know
the demand for for those a and B drugs
so what you sleep what is the next step
you sleep so till now what we have done
through data science is the to risk that
we had one was the demand risk be kind
of got the demand and the other was the
approval risk and we got the probability
still the next part in risk management
of this kinetics is to make sure or
create different scenarios on that cases
which is what we did in this case so
what we did in this case was basically
i'll just try to explain to you or this
whole tree means what we have done here
is we have tried to calculate the net
present cost over five years for each of
the scenarios so if you have so you
basically have a decision that you have
to make there are if you can see there
is a and B the two drugs I hope you are
able to see it let me the sleeves are
trying to spotlight would be good so
this is a one drug deep another drug and
the decision basically that we needed to
make was should we go for a specialized
unit or should we go for a flexible unit
now if you look at this person taste
fifteen percent this is the probability
that i am talking about through data
science we found out or through
different models whether it was through
lost it regression or whether it is
through neural network what I found out
was that this is the probability of drug
a being approved so you can you can look
at
both the scenarios I am trying to create
scenarios which is fifteen percent and
fifteen percent for success in
eighty-five percent for failure if that
is the case 75.2 for its in USD million
this is basically the net present cost
if it's a success if it's a failure as
in if the drug is not produced and we go
in and set up our specialized in it
anyways because you have to take a
decision today right we need to decide
today whether we need to set up a
specialized unit or a flexible unit so I
need to go and put in the money today in
that case we lose basically around 50.5
seven or this is the total cost in this
case if we set up a flexible unit and
this is the 50 4.27 is the expected net
present cost so that is basically 75.2
for x 0 point 15 plus 50.5 7 x 0 point
eight five and this is the expected net
present cost that you get for a
specialized unit for a similarly for a
flexible unit if the successes fifteen
percent the net present cost it has a
116 point zero one and if it's a failure
then the net present cost is zero so you
can understand the implications of how
risk is playing with our decision today
if the drug is not a prude and I go and
put in a flexible unit I lose nothing
zero cost if it's a success with a given
demand that we have with the given
demand that we have the cost is pretty
huge if we compare it with a specialized
one you will find that if its success
with the given demand the cost is lesser
than the cost from a flexible unit so
it's a success I will go and put in a
specialized blind if it's a failure I
will go and try to put a flexible plan
but life is not so easy because you mean
you don't know whether it's going to be
a success or a failure there is a
probability attached to it that's why
you take the expected value so you have
50 4.27 coming from for this particular
success for the ability you have the net
present cost X of T 4.27 and flexible as
17.4 0 so with this given demand with
this probability successful ability I
will go in for a flexible unit because
it costs me less to put a flexible unit
then I specialize in it for this success
probability now same is the case for
drug B and of course if there are more
than two he will go on and create more
scenarios on that basis now our work has
not finished up until now we need to now
do some more scenario analysis or we
need to do more sensitivity analysis
where now we change the probabilities
and then accordingly find out what is at
what place should I have specialized and
and not flexible because in this case
what did we choose which we chose that
flexible unit needs to be chosen given
this probability so with sensitivity
analysis we'll find out at what
probability i need to do specialized and
not flex / just a second
okay so this is how we did it so as you
can see there's an input probability for
a and B and this point 15.24 comes from
your model it comes from your logistic
model it comes from with neural network
model and it gets and it gets put here
in the scenario analysis and that on
that basis the net present cost and I am
not showing it here because i do not go
into the more details of course i have a
model working in a sheet excel sheet i
am also putting in the demand that we
got from forecasting because if I don't
have the demand I will not be able to
calculate the cost I need to understand
how much I need to produce right so this
net present cost is the cost of setting
up the unit and is also the cost of
producing those units over a period of
five years that's why it is named as net
present cost so this net present cost
actually contains both the things that
we calculated the demand for that drug
and the probability of approval for that
drop this is where you basically you
basically do the scenario analysis and
and come out with ways in which we
should be ready to to produce or ways in
which we should be ready to implement a
specialized unit or a or a flexible unit
okay so this is where the scenario
analysis ends the next topic is more
about if risk analytics is so good when
are the instances when it doesn't work
well it doesn't work if you do not have
the past data you only have the future
or the current data in that case it's
very very difficult this is a case where
if you have people who have subject
matter expertise who have been there for
let's say more than 15-20 years
at times they know much much more then
what risk analytics is going to tell you
and thirdly the accuracy of the
variables that you are measuring it's
very very important the waivers that you
will measure to create your models if
they are not accurate enough then the
values that you are going to get and the
scenario is the risk scenarios that you
create are not to go to help you out in
any way just to repeat myself when there
is no history or Poseidon related to
risk being considered or when historical
data may not be contextually right this
is that this is one of the reasons where
this I'll explain not one secondly as
already mentioned when decision makers
have legitimate expertise and decision
making is strategic in nature I
mentioned that earlier right if
something is strategic usually it is
done for a timeline of five years ten
years of opinions and you would like to
make sure that you are you will
complement your analysis with data
rather than make it the basis for your
decision making and thirdly when key
variables can be measured accurately or
can be measured at all in that case you
are better off not doing a risk
analytics tools which are being used for
some of the examples that I just showed
you so it's it's basically you have are
you have sass you have SPSS you have
MicroStrategy you are faker you have
tableau and surprisingly was not
surprisingly you have Excel to I think
that's like one of the most popular
tools that so i have not like put it on
the on the slide here next steps for all
of you so i have put it into like three
buckets one is you need to educate
yourself in whichever in whichever
domain or in whichever
in the Venn diagram that I showed in
whichever area you are in whether you
are a domain expert trying to go into
data science whether you are someone who
knows data science we are trying to go
into this particular domain or thirdly
you you are someone who is interested in
both of them what you need to do is
start to educate yourself and I'm just
talking right now more from a technical
perspective because domain expertise is
not is easy as in that domain expertise
you need to have some kind of an
experience that is the most valuable
education that you get but for the other
part which is the data science part
there are a lot of things that you can
learn segmentation statistical
clustering predictive models event
simulation scenario analysis the lot of
statistical and machine learning
concepts like regression which is like
the most popular and almost anyone use
it but you'd be surprised to know that
many people don't use regression in the
right way nevertheless so you have
bootstrapping you have clustering
decision trees these are all like
machine learning concepts you can learn
all of them through different tools you
have our SAS you excel you have Hadoop
you try to remain in the ecosystem so
it's basically that if you want to be in
data science and risk management you
need to somehow be in this ecosystem a
couple of places where you could go and
join India there's something called
consortium for data analytics in risk
and there are other communities like
Society for risk analysis so you could
just go and be a part of these
communities and thirdly the most
important is application in whichever
business face you are you are in you
need to make sure that you start
applying it of course you want to do it
on a small scale or a pilot skills so
that you can show it to your higher
management and and basically at least
have some kind of a wind on your sins
before you go in and do it big time so
that's why I said the third part is
actually the application part so
if you if you if you are in all these or
you you educate yourself you're in the
ecosystem and you try to apply that
those are the the best things that you
could do to learn risk analytics that's
it from my end if there is any other
questions from jordan i am happy to
answer all of you
can all thank you so much and we're
going to take a look at the questions
here and one of the most common question
and I'll handle this one real quick as a
couple of people if after this is is
there a going to be a copy of video
recording of this session that they can
loop back around and watch again in the
future at their leisure and the answer
that is yes all of our sessions are
recorded it takes some time to put the
recording through our production team
and get it ready for posting to my
knowledge these are then posted to the
YouTube channel for simply learned so
you can go ahead and go to youtube find
the simply learned channel and subscribe
to that and you should see any new
recordings showing up there and i
believe they also perhaps go into the
simply learn platform for members to
access so that's that should answer the
question for a couple of folks on that
sort of thing we are a couple of folks
here sir asking about the the most
appropriate tools and skills and
additional trainings that one might need
in other words you know I guess the best
way to present the question would be you
know aside from a specific analytics or
risk management training and
certification what other kinds of tools
or skill sets or certifications might
one need to pursue python tableau FAS we
have a couple of folks asking about what
may be the most valuable additional
skill sets would be for someone to
pursue sure so actually depends upon the
answer to most of the questions is
usually it depends just going to more
deep details it's it's actually the
scope or the function or the industry in
which you're trying to go to there is
not like one tool or an overarching tool
which does want to select every industry
or every kind of analysis just to give
you an example let's talk about
up our SAS Excel and Python let's say
and just like kind of comparing these
four tools right if I take the example
of our it's an open source tool and it's
it's easy to do it yourself individually
it's easy buy-in from your management
because you can go and tell them that
it's a 3 out tool if there is a new kind
of a model that comes in from the
Academy ax it's easy to replicate it in
our because there are people who will do
it for you through different packages
talking about SAS I think it has been
used for like more than two decades now
so it is much much more extensive and it
has much much it's much easier to do a
SAS rather than to learn our as and if
you don't want to put in that effort
there is a good user interface in SAS so
that's like pretty easy for you to begin
with of course it comes with us or
licensing fees and other things it has
support whereas in our it's more like
more community-driven going on into
Excel adding many of us still use Excel
and Excel is a very very powerful tool
you can you can still do so much of
canales in Excel it is very very easy
very very intuitive and many of us
already know there are integrations that
that Excel can have with SAS or or with
are specifically talking about Python i
think i saw that question to their some
people asked about python that is it's
it's also python is actually if you are
not a programmer it's little difficult
to learn as in its its but if you are a
programmer it's like one of the best
analytical tools that you have today so
if you haven't learned programming or
you don't know programming before it is
better to move to an odd or a SAS or
rather than a Python but if you already
are programming
you know python then is easy to to jump
from programming to analytics because
there are a lot of good packages even in
Python they're like numpy their lot of
good packages in Python too so it
depends it depends completely on the
industry like if you want to do time for
casting you'd rather go to SAS if you
want to do complex analysis like your
network you would rather go to our
because you won't have it in sask of
course XL is like useless in both the
cases because of the amount of data that
you have to deal with and Python again
you can do both but it's not easy to do
that's what I i I'll stop there yeah I
know that's perfect and I think that you
answered several people's questions
there by getting into those specific
tools so I appreciate that I hope that
answers your question in wawa and
divyansh hopefully we address what you
were sort of trying to get out there and
a couple of folks are asking about first
steps or next steps in pursuing a career
in risk analytics and you sort of
addressed that in your final couple of
slides I am going to post into the chat
module folks take a look at your
dashboard not for the question module
look for the chat module and I'm posting
a couple of links there one of them is a
link to some articles on the simply
learn site about risk management and
career opportunities and education
opportunities and trends and so forth
and the other link is a link to the
search for data scientist under the
courses section of our site and that
will give you a jumpstart on finding
some of the available courses for you
and then of course you can always ask
our support team to help you find the
appropriate course fell to to meet your
needs vikas is asking two questions here
one of you mentioned bootstrapping in
one of your you're late late slides and
if we could just clarify what the term
bootstrapping means and then the second
question photographs is how do we do
predictive analysis and Hadoop is there
a particular tool that you
that you recommend for predictive
analysis in Hadoop okay so i'll answer
Buddha questions so I'll not go too much
into detail about bootstrapping but it's
basically a technique through which you
multiply your data for your analysis for
you analysis but just just to give you
an example let's say that you are trying
to analyze let's say you trying to
forecast a demand for our brand yeah of
a company let's say it's a watch Brad
and you just have 50 records and you
would want to do analysis on that and
try to do a forecasting now the problem
is that we just for 50 records it's not
easy to do a good forecasting and it is
very very difficult to get an accurate
forecasting so in that case you use
bootstrapping which is basically you
will create data from that 50 data
records so it is a method through which
from that 50 records you create more
samples and instead of 50 you can have
like 50,000 records just from 50 records
and it is a very popular technique and
in fact the guy who found out that model
actually got an award in the analytics
world for that so you can go into
details of of that the second question
is is it necessary to learn Hadoop I saw
or how is like Hadoop use for predictive
analytics so Hadoop is actually I guess
you already know it's like a file system
kind of a tool where what you do is is
mostly it is used for unstructured data
and if you have to really do some
predictive modeling on top of it one you
have to write a code on it and if you
want to avoid writing those codes and
you want to use the already available
packages that are already there you
could just connect Hadoop with our
so in one of in one of the project that
I have done the what we had done was we
had used Hadoop to clean the
unstructured data or the eater from
social media which had come in and then
we use the data that Hadoop you two are
did the analysis and then showed it
through a tableau because tableau is
usually used as more like a visual it's
like a mode of visual tool of course it
has its own analytic capabilities but
that's how we did it there is no right
or wrong answer but it's easier if you
know these other tools which can
integrate with a group perfect thank you
so much for that we have time I think
for one more question or we run the risk
of pushing the next webinar into a late
start as well and I think we can look at
naveen's question from earlier in the
session Naveen is interested in
correlating outliers with stock market
movement and trends are there specific
strategies or techniques or tools that
you might recommend for correlating
stock market data with with your own
data so i would say that you should look
at certain packages so they must talk
MKT packages in our so i haven't gone
into the details of it as in that i
haven't done it myself but i would
strongly suggest that there are certain
stock market packages in our if you know
our where there are models which are
already made what you just need to do is
kind of as simply as put in the data
stock market data and then it will
identify the outliers and it will try to
model on that basis so I would suggest
that just look at those financial
solution in in our itself perfect thank
you so much folks we are up at it's 45
minutes past
yeah now we may not be able to get to
all the questions but I want to thank
everybody for bearing with us with our
late start and I hope we were able to
give you enough information to make this
all as fascinating as it was for me I'm
going to share one last link into your
chat module and that's going to point
you at the page where the upcoming
webinars for simply learn are listed so
take a look at that and please feel free
to scroll down the list and join
register for as many of those free
webinars as you would like to join we'd
be happy to have you on board it's
always a pleasure and and we love having
a big group with lots of really smart
questions so with that we are at the end
of our session can all thank you so much
for being here it's always fun to hang
out with you lots of great information
you